[Music]
so I'm really fascinated by the way that
context affects consciousness you know
we're set and setting meet awareness and
consciousness so why do people like
sunrises why do people love sunsets and
I think it's because it's a moment in
which we can actually witness the
transformation the transition from day
to night
or from night today in ordinary waking
states we cannot perceive the passing of
the moment and so this perception this
this increased juxtaposition of day and
night forces us to be more present it
forces an experience of time dilation
that transforms how we perceive the
moment the moment becomes impregnated
with a sense of importance with a sense
of meaningfulness the sunset context
essentially frames the moment and
induces hopefully a transformative
experience and thus we are left that
feeling of oh that was really meaningful
or oh that was really special and we
crave these moments and we work hard for
these moments and we strive to author
these moments but a lot of times they
are right there for the taking if only
we were aware enough to open our eyes
and plug in
[Music]